But as it is written,
eye hath not seen,
nor ear heard,
neither have entered into the heart of
man the things which God hath prepared
for them that love him.
1 Corinthians chapter 2 verse 9.
Greetings and happy Sabbath one and all.
Welcome to Q&A on the word inspired with
Elder Randy Skeete. I'm your host
Denisha McCurchen and today we are
discussing the new world. Before we go
any further further, let us have a word
of prayer.
Father, we are grateful for your
presence on this your holy Sabbath day
of rest. And as we delve into what you
have prepared for us, I pray Lord that
our minds will be fixed upon your truth.
And as you use your man servant Elder
Randy Skeete to answer these questions
that you would put your words in his
mouth, your humility in his heart, your
ideas in his mind so that as he speaks,
oh God, your spirit will cut through the
hearts of men.
Be with us, oh God.
We bless your name in Jesus' name. Amen.
Well, our special guest for this
afternoon is a part of the word inspired
family. He is a renowned speaker, has
traveled internationally and nationally
to declare the word of the Lord and his
mission is that people will hear the
truth through his life, not only what he
declares, but in his actions. And I
speak of none other than Elder Randy
Skeete. He has studied for the ministry
at Oakwood University and the
Theological Seminary at Andrews
University. He's married to sister
Skeete and he is a father of many and
mentor to many. I pray that you give him
a very warm virtual welcome as he joins
us, oops, joins us this afternoon. I'm
sorry, I think I accidentally muted you
instead of spotlighting you there, Elder
Skeete. So you can feel free to unmute
yourself.
Ah.
Let's
There we go. There we go. Welcome.
Welcome, Elder Skeete. Thank you very
much. God bless you.
I'm happy to be here. Always am.
Ah, amen. We are so blessed to have you
as well, Elder Skeete. Any opening
remarks before we transition to the
questions?
Well, as always, I thank God for your
ministry, my good Dr. Denisha.
It is, whether you know it or not, a
blessing to people all over the world.
And how do I know that? Cuz the Lord
sends me all over the world and I bump
into people who listen to your Q&A's and
they are blessed. So I thank God for it.
And I thank him for allowing me to be a
part of it and I say that very very
sincerely. So thank you for allowing me
to be a part of what you do for the
kingdom.
Amen. Amen. Praise God. Thank you, Elder
Skeete, for encouraging me to keep
going.
Amen.
So let us begin with our first question.
What is the new world?
What is it characterized by?
And how will it be different from the
new heaven?
What is the new world? What is it
characterized by?
How will How will it be different, you
said, from the old world? Okay.
In the new world is exactly what the
word says. God will create
a brand new world and a brand new
heavens.
The heavens associated with this world
are both contaminated, the heavens and
the earth. So God has to make a new
heaven and a new earth. Now, why does he
Because this one is deteriorating.
We see that in Hebrews 1, reading from
verse 10. I'll allow you to find that
passage. Hebrews 1, reading from verse
10, we'll find out why God has to make a
new heaven and a new earth.
In this chapter, God the Father is
addressing the Son.
Here's what he says to the Son, verse 10
of Hebrews 1. And thou, Lord, in the
beginning Oh, go ahead, Denisha. Go
ahead.
Yes, yes. And thou, Lord, in the
beginning has laid the foundation of the
earth and the heavens are the works of
thine hands.
Father identifies Christ as the creator
of heaven and earth. If the Father
identifies him that way, I am not
arguing with the Father. Jesus Christ is
the creator and sustainer of heaven and
earth. Now, listen to what the Father
says in the next verse.
They all shall perish, but thou
remainest.
Now, pause. They all shall perish. What
is all? Well, in verse 10 we have heaven
and we have earth.
And so they all shall perish, everything
in the heavens, everything in the earth
will perish.
Now, you can finish all of verse 11.
They shall all wax old as doth a
garment.
Mhm. Go on.
And as a vesture
And as a vesture thou shalt fold them up
and they shall be changed.
Mhm. But thou art the same and thy years
shall not fail.
So the Father tells Christ what Christ
already knows.
But we're learning. The Father said,
"This first heaven and this first earth
will pass away. They are wearing away
like an old garment." The question is,
why did that happen? Because of sin.
When Adam sinned, the whole earth The
whole earth was cursed.
And of course, the heavens associated
with the earth also came under that to
some degree. And so God has to remake
heaven and remake earth.
A brand new world, a brand new heaven,
in order to put brand new people in that
brand new world. And so it is because of
sin
that God has to make a new heaven and a
new earth. Let me also say, anything
cursed by sin cannot exist forever. It
must come to an end because sin has
death in it. Whether it's the death of a
person or the death of an ecosystem,
anything cursed by sin must eventually
come to an end. And so the earth is on a
spiral, a downward spiral, towards
certain destruction. We read about that
in 2 Peter chapter 3 verse 10. We can go
to that passage.
2 Peter 3 verse 10.
Behold, the day cometh
that shall burn as an oven.
Go on. Oh, yes. Oh, is that Malachi 4?
Should I go there first, Elder Skeete?
Oh, sorry. That's Malachi
But the day of the Lord shall come as a
thief
But the day of the Lord
Yes. Yes. But the day of the Lord will
come as a thief in the night, in the
which the heavens shall pass away with a
great noise and the elements shall melt
with fervent heat.
Uh-huh. The earth also and the works
that are therein shall be burned
have heaven and earth will be consumed
and they will both be remade. Why Now,
let's read verse 13 to see what we can
look forward to.
Yes. Nevertheless,
we, according to his promise, look for
new heavens and new earth wherein
dwelleth righteousness. Because right
now, righteousness does not predominate
on this earth. Notice I said, it does
not It's not predominant feature. The
predominant feature is sin and sin
carries death. And so God has to get us
off this sinking ship, remake this world
and then put us in it to live forever.
So the reason why there's need for a new
heaven and a new earth is because the
first heaven and the first earth were
contaminated
by sin.
Amen. And then part of the question was,
what will characterize the new heaven
and the new earth? Righteousness.
2 Peter chapter 3 verse 13.
Nevertheless, we, according to his
promise, look for new heavens and the
new earth wherein dwelleth
righteousness,
which was God's original arrangement
before Adam and Eve sinned. God will
restore and the purpose of the gospel is
to restore, not only in us the image of
God, but ultimately to restore the world
and the heavens associated with the
world. It is only when that is done that
the entire plan of salvation would have
been finally fulfilled.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Amen. Uh, thank you so
much, Elder Skeete, for allowing us to
understand that God will not allow a
sin-cursed earth
to house holy people or even his
presence. Yes. Righteousness will reign
upon the earth and God is making the new
world, a new earth and new heavens. So
And you touched actually upon the next
question, which was, why does God have
to make a new world? Because of sin.
Yes, because of sin. But how will the
old world be destroyed?
Well, we go to a Well,
earlier I Yes, mentioned uh Malachi
chapter 4 verse 1. Let's go there. And
then we can come back to 2 Peter 3:10.
Malachi 4 verse 1 and verse 2.
Behold,
For behold, the day cometh that shall
burn as an oven. Mhm.
the proud, yea, and all that do wickedly
shall be stubble. Mhm.
What produces stubble? Fire.
And so fire is the agent of destruction
in this uh of this world. This is God's
choice because fire as an agent of
destruction not only destroys, but it
purifies. When God destroyed the world
in the days of Noah, the waters
destroyed, but did not purify.
The fires will destroy, consume, and
purify. And so the world will be
destroyed by fire. This is no joke. The
entire world will be a ball of fire.
Right now, the whole world looks like a
ball of water.
The main When you're out in space, the
thing you see most is water.
When Christ destroys this world, it will
be a ball of fire.
And that's biblical truth. There's
nothing funny about it.
We have to hold on to Christ to make
sure we're not in that ball of fire,
but safe with him when this world is
destroyed. So fire is the agent of God's
destruction as it was in the days of
Sodom and Gomorrah.
Amen. Amen.
Um and you know, I I just want to add
this other verse, Elder Skeete. You
know, God is going to destroy this world
by fire, and in order for us to be in
the new world, we also need to pass
through the fire.
Well, yes.
In Revelation Yes, Revelation 3:21,
Jesus says, "Buy of me gold tried in the
fire that thou mayest be rich." So we
too need to be purified to live on a
pure earth.
So Elder
That's 3:18. That's Revelation 3:18. Oh,
thank you. 3:18. Thank you.
all right. That's it.
21 is to him that overcometh.
That's right. Yes.
So Elder Skeete,
when the when will the world be made
new? So when does this destruction take
place? The world is made new at the end
of the 1,000 years.
Satan and his evil angels will be stuck
on this earth
for a period of 1,000 years.
No one to tempt, nothing to do. They
cannot leave, cannot travel. During that
time, we'll be with Christ in heaven
looking at the punishment assigned to
the lost.
When that period ends, then Christ comes
back. You can read Revelation chapter
20. All the the wicked dead are
resurrected to see why they're about to
destroyed. They will understand that
what they're about to suffer is just and
right. That has to happen. When that is
when that happens, of course, part of
the the events at the end of the 1,000
years, Satan will try to take the city
of God. Because when Christ comes, the
city comes with him, and it sits on a
particular a place specially set aside.
Satan will arouse the lost nations to
take the city. Revelation 20:9, verse
10. Fire will come down from heaven and
devour them.
And verse 14 of Revelation 20 and verse
15, those who are not found written in
the book of life shall also be cast into
the lake of fire. When all of that is
done, then God makes a new heaven. And
so we have the destruction in chapter 20
of Revelation. We have the new heaven,
new earth in chapter 21.
Amen. Amen.
Now, Elder Skeete,
when God makes this new world,
what will its relationship be to God's
throne?
Revelation 21, let's read verse 3.
Revelation Well, let's read from verse 1
of Revelation 21. We read 1 to 3.
Yes.
And I saw a new heaven and a new earth.
For the first heaven and the first earth
were passed away, and there was no more
sea.
And I John
saw the holy city, New Jerusalem, coming
down from God out of heaven, prepared as
a bride adorned for her husband.
Now, we have the capital city
of the universe, the New Jerusalem,
coming down. It will no longer be where
God is in heaven. It will be situated on
the new earth. This is astonishing. The
capital city of the universe will be
situated on this brand new earth. Now
let's read verse 3.
And I heard a great voice out of heaven
saying, "Behold, the tabernacle of God
is with man, and he will dwell with
them, and they shall be his people, and
God himself shall be with them and be
their God."
God's
headquarters will be transformed
trans
relocated to this world made new.
It is astonishing that of all the worlds
in the universe, and the Bible suggests
that inhabited worlds, God will place
his headquarters on this earth made new
by the power of the creator, Jesus
Christ. And so the relationship is that
the the nerve center of heaven,
the cockpit of heaven,
the rule the office of divinity will be
located on this earth. A tremendous
honor God is paying to those who are
redeemed by the blood of Christ and will
live with him forever. Tremendous honor
that God will put his headquarters, and
he will be with us closer than with any
other being on any other world that have
not fallen.
It almost seems You know, to our human
minds, it seems unfair that we could be
so blessed and honored by God.
But that's the goodness of God.
Amen. Amen. You know, Elder Skeete, as
you share that that uh truth, I think
about the prodigal son. You know, after
he left and the Holy Spirit worked upon
him and he came back, the father loved
him even more. He was even more dear to
the to to his son because his son came
back to truth. And in that same way, as
you said, it's not the natural thing to
do. You know, when he strays away and or
if we have a friend that strays away and
then they decide to come back into our
lives and like, "Okay, you want to come
back in?" But God says, "No, I'm going
to be exactly where you are." He extends
his benevolent love to us. And your
expression that the father loved him
even more, that's also an experience in
the life of Christ. If you read John
10:17, we can go there. John 10:17.
Very, very interesting verse.
We often read it and we read it
casually.
It gives a tremendous truth. Read verse
17. Therefore, Therefore doth my father
love me
because I lay down my life that I may
take it might take it again. In other
words, because of Christ's sacrifice, in
a way we cannot understand, the love for
the fa- the father's love for his son
deepened and widened and thickened.
The father loved him before he laid down
his life, but Jesus said, "Therefore
doth my father love me." Somehow, God's
love for his son, however that happened,
was deepened by the fact that the son
would lay down his life for sinners. And
so yes, the prodigal son received even
more love when he came back home. And
God will honor the redeemed
by making their presence the place of
his headquarters.
Well, the redeemed will also be honored
by the fact that Christ will always have
human flesh, always have his eternal. So
that's a tremendous honor. He will look
just like us throughout eternity. Still
be God, but look human.
He'll be both, not just look human,
he'll be both.
That honor cannot be measured.
Thank you. Thank you, Elder Skeete.
So
God is making this new heaven, this new
earth. Who will enter the new world?
Revelation 22:14. Let's go there.
Excellent question.
It's not by lottery tickets.
You don't get crushed in the new world.
Revelation 22:14. Read for us.
Blessed are they that do his
commandments
that they may have right to the tree of
life
and may enter in through the gates into
the city. Now keep this in mind. Blessed
are they that do his commandments. One
word for that, obey.
Keep this in mind. Let's read Romans
5:19.
We're contrasting the first Adam with
the second Adam. See what led to this
earth being cursed. Romans 5:19.
For as by one man's disobedience,
many were made sinners.
So by the obedience of one shall many be
made righteous.
The key is obedience. Because of
disobedience, Adam and Eve were thrown
out. Because of obedience through
Christ, we will have access
to the tree of life and the place in
God's unending kingdom. The key is
the obedience of faith.
No disobedient person will set foot in
God's kingdom because sin will begin all
over again, and God has guaranteed us
iniquity shall not rise the second time.
Revelation 22:3, there shall be no more
curse. Why? Because there shall be no
more sin.
Obedience is what God wants.
That qualifies us for a place in God's
kingdom. The obedience of Christ lived
out through us.
Amen.
So once we are there, by God's grace, by
faith,
in the new world, what will we be doing
there?
Whatever it was Adam was told by God to
do, we will do.
You see, a life in the new world is not
a life floating around in the
atmosphere.
There'll be houses to build, inhabit,
vineyards to plant, because Adam had to
eat, he has to take care of the garden,
he has things to do. We will have things
to do. Now, since the headquarters of
the universe will be on this earth, we
may correctly assume we will assist God
in the administration of the entire
universe, not just this earth. So, there
will be things to do we cannot now
imagine, and each one will be a joy.
But, because we'll be physical and
human, we have to take care of
ourselves, we have to eat, we have to do
all of that, we have to sleep, we have
to live somewhere. All of that. The
difference is there will be no more sin.
Another difference is God will dwell
personally. He won't come to visit as he
did uh in Adam's case. This is where he
will live. He won't be a visitor. This
is where he will live. And so, there
will be so many things for us to do
of which we're not now aware. It will
not be an idle life.
Mhm. Managing the entire universe, which
no one can measure.
I I read somewhere that our galaxy, the
Milky Way, is so huge. If you travel at
the speed of light, it'd take you
200,000 years to cross from one end to
the other. Traveling at the speed of
light to cross the Milky Way, and there
are billions of galaxies. There'll be so
much
for us to do.
Mhm. Mhm. Because God is an orderly God,
you see. Things have to be kept in
order.
And the same way in the book of Job, the
sons of God would come to God to report
to him, to discuss what's going on.
Because God gave them responsibilities,
the same thing will happen again.
Amen. Mhm. Amen.
Amen. You know, Elder Skeete, it's so
interesting how you mentioned that God
is not idle. Mhm. You know, often when
we think about Sodom and Gomorrah, you
know, of course we we can identify the
abomination, but when the Bible speaks
about the sin of Sodom and Gomorrah, one
of the first things that he mentions is
idleness. Okay.
Abundance of idleness was in their
hands. And if we see that the earth will
be destroyed by fire as Sodom and
Gomorrah was,
Mhm. which was in contrast to the word
of God, in contrast to the character and
law of God, we now need to start
preparing ourselves and not being idle.
We need to wake up and work, because
that's what will characterize the new
world. That's right.
All right, a little aside. In any case,
Work is a defense against the devil.
Work is a defense against sin and its
temptations. Work contributes to
character development. I mean, working
God's way, working honestly, working
righteously, they are Work is a defense
against temptation, and it is a means to
develop character. Character will
continue to develop in the new world,
because the ultimate aim is godliness,
God-likeness. There's no end to the
progress towards God-likeness. Because
God is infinite, there will be no end to
our growth, our growth, our growth. And
so, the work we have in the new world
will contribute to the development of
our character.
Amen. Amen.
Now, we spoke about the work that we'll
be doing in the new world, but will we
be keeping the seventh-day Sabbath rest?
Yes. Isaiah 66. Let's read 22 and 23.
Isaiah 66: 22 and 23.
Very good question.
For as the new heavens and the new earth
which I will make, shall remain before
me, saith the Lord.
pause right there.
We discussed the old heaven and the old
earth. Notice what Isaiah says, under
the guidance of the Holy Spirit, "For as
the new heavens and the new earth which
I will make shall remain." In other
words, the first one will not remain,
you see.
But, the second time around, this one
will remain, which tells us clearly
there will never be sin again.
Because if sin were to enter, it
wouldn't remain. And so, Isaiah says,
"As the new heaven and the new earth
which I will make shall remain." Remain
means forever.
Mhm. On.
So shall your seed and your name remain.
Wow, what a promise. Forever.
And it shall come to pass that from one
new moon to another, Yes.
and from one Sabbath to another, Mhm.
shall all flesh come to worship before
me, saith the Lord. That's the new
world. Now, that that prophecy has a
dual application. It refers to the
return of the Jews to their homeland,
where they will worship God in the
earth, but it also has a higher
application when we
are placed by God in the brand new
world. There's no more The enemy of sin
is not with Not the enemy of sin. Satan
is not alive anymore. Sin is not a
contaminant that that affects us. All of
that is gone. We can worship God freely
and fully and eternally from one new
moon to another, from one Sabbath to
another. This is long as there is
creation, there will be the Sabbath.
So, yes, in the new world, the one
commandment mentioned clearly is the
Sabbath. Well, the others will be there
in some form or fashion. Yes, you won't
be killing and committing whatever else,
but the Sabbath is identified, it is
singled out.
That's the one that allows us to honor
God
and remind us of who he is.
And that is because of him
that we are alive.
Yes, the Sabbath will be kept in the new
world, but we practice for that by
keeping the Sabbath now.
Amen. Amen. Amen. Wait until the new
world comes to live like a new world
person.
By faith, we live a new world life now.
That's why the Bible says of Abraham, he
looked for a city which had Of course,
that's getting to one of the other
questions you have. I'll leave it to you
to ask it. But, we must live a new world
life now in this old world. That's
living by faith.
Yes. Yes.
So, our next question, Elder Skeete,
what is the significance of meditating
upon the new world? Let's go to Hebrews
chapter 11.
We'll read from verse 8.
We go to 10. Hebrews 11: 8 to 10.
By faith, Mhm. Abraham, when he was
called to go out into a place which he
should after receive for an inheritance,
obeyed.
And he went out, not knowing whither he
went. Mhm.
By faith, he sojourned in the land of
promise as in a strange country,
dwelling in tabernacles with Isaac and
Jo- Jacob, the heirs with him of the
same promise. Uh let's look at verse 9
again. By faith, he sojourned in the
land of promise.
Promise.
Now, that land was promised, but without
leaving Hebrews 11, let's go to Romans 4
and read verse 13.
For the promise
Mhm. that he should be the heir of the
world
Yes.
was not to Abraham
Abraham. or to his seed
uh-huh, through the law, but by but
through the righteousness
of faith. What I wanted to stress is
that the promise that he would be the
heir of the world. So, when Abraham
dwelt in Canaan, which was promised to
his descendants, he also had the
understanding that Canaan represented
the larger world to come to which he
would be he was an heir.
You understand?
Yes. So, Abraham lived in Canaan,
a particular section on the earth, but
with the mental attitude that one day
the entire world would be a global
Canaan, and he would be a part of that
world. So, he lived in Canaan, but his
mind his thinking was the Canaan to
come. And your question is, how what
mindset should we have in this new
world? Now, read verse 10.
For he looked for a city
which hath foundations, whose builder
and maker is God.
Yes, he looked. He was expecting. His
mind was in heaven, even though he lived
on the earth.
Now, that's Hebrews
11: 8 to 10. But,
God told Abraham in Genesis 13. Let's go
to Genesis 13. As we look at the new
world again,
which was represented by Canaan.
Yes.
This two fulfillments. Canaan was given
to the Israelites physically, it'll be
given to them again on a broader scale.
Now, let's read from verse 13 of Genesis
13. Lot has separated from Abraham.
He's gone to where Sodom and Gomorrah
is. Let's read from verse 13 of Genesis
13. Well, let's pray again first.
Father, as we continue to answer
questions, give us wisdom, I pray, in
Jesus' name. Amen. Go ahead. Amen.
But, the men of Sodom were wicked Mhm.
and sinners before the Lord exceedingly.
Mhm.
And the Lord said unto Abram, Mhm. after
that Lot was separated from him, Yes.
"Lift up now thine eyes, and look from
the place where thou art northward, and
southward, and eastward, and westward
Keep going.
For all the land
Mhm. which thou seest, to thee will I
give it
Mhm. and to thy seed forever. Now, where
did God tell Abraham to look?
In Northward.
every direction. Southward.
Eastward. Those are the four points of
the compass.
God was telling Abraham to look at the
entire world.
I will give it to you and your seed. So,
even while he lived in Canaan, which had
its boundaries, he understood that one
day this Canaan would be the entire
world. Keep in mind in Galatians 3:8,
the Bible said this God preached the
gospel to Abraham.
And the gospel includes the new world
where the redeemed will live. God
preached the gospel to Abraham. Abraham
understood
that Canaan symbolized the whole new
world to come when there would be no sin
and all his descendants would be the
inhabitants of this world. And so, the
question again, what should be our
mental attitude towards the new world?
We should keep it on our minds.
Mhm.
There must be something, you see, that
distracts us from the constant
irritations of living in this world.
What do I mean by distracts us? Let's go
to Hebrews 12. Let me show you what I
mean.
Yes, Hebrews 12. Let's read 1 and 2.
Wherefore Mhm. seeing we are compassed
about with so great a cloud of witnesses
Mhm. let us lay aside every weight
Weight. Mhm. and the sin which doth so
easily beset us Mhm.
and let us run with patience the race
that is set before us. Keep going.
Looking unto Jesus
Yes. the author
Author. and finisher of our faith.
Carefully now, read microscopically. Who
Who for the joy that was set before him
Pause right there. There's a joy set
before Jesus. While he was in the Garden
of Gethsemane, suffering, something was
placed before him. And Ellen White tells
us the angels that came down showed him
all those who would be saved if he went
through with it. So, something was
placed before him that meant more to him
than his suffering. Are you following
me? For the joy set before him endured
the cross, despising the shame. There
must be something set before us that
takes our mind off the present trials
and tribulations. Go to Romans chapter
8. Let's read verse 18. See how that
worked for Paul.
This is psychologically important, not
only spiritually.
Romans 8:18.
For I reckon
Uh-huh. that the sufferings of this
present time
Mhm. are not worthy to be compared with
the glory which shall be revealed in us.
Now, wait a minute. We have two things
in that verse now, and we're still
answering the question, what should be
our mental state towards this new world?
Paul says, I reckon that the suffering
Now, he acknowledges we are suffering.
The ex-sufferings of this present world
are not worthy to be compared with the
glory. And so, Paul's focus is not on
the suffering, but on the glory. Paul
does not ignore that he has to sleep and
eat and go to the bathroom. He doesn't
ignore that. He's simply saying, "Look,
there's something bigger than this
that's coming. That's where my focus
is." And when Christ was in the Garden
of Gethsemane, three times he prayed,
"Father, get me out of this." The father
sent an angel to show, "Look,
if you go through with this this is what
will happen." And so, for the joy that
was set before him And for those
listening to this Q&A session, what is
the joy set before you? Your father
Abraham looked for a city. That's where
his mind was even while he took care of
day-to-day duty. My good sister, Dr.
Danisha, you are in medical school.
What's the joy set before you? Walking
across that stage, getting your MD
degree, serving those who are in need,
representing God. That's the joys. And
because of that, you suffered through
anatomy and physiology
and biochemistry. Why? For the joy set
before you.
And so, the new world must be a joy set
I want to be a part of that world, and
I'm not allowing the trials of this
world to prevent me from entering God's
kingdom. The joy of the world to come
must far exceed the little sufferings we
have in this temporary life. And so,
Paul says, "I reckon that the sufferings
of this present life are not worthy to
be compared." There's no comparison with
the glory that shall be revealed in us.
Abraham lived in Canaan, but he looked
for a city. He looked.
And Jesus in Gethsemane, bleeding
through his skin, he looked and he saw
those who would be saved. The joy set
before him. And if we do not have a joy
set before us, all we will be doing is
crying and wailing and weeping and
complaining and suffering.
Amen. Amen. Amen. You know, Aldis Keith,
you mentioned that word joy and my mind
has The Lord has brought me to John
chapter 17:13
Okay.
where Jesus he says, "And now come I to
thee, and these things I speak in the
world that they may have my
joy.
joy fulfilled in themselves."
Yes. As Jesus went to the Father, we too
have that joy to look forward to. Mhm.
As you said, Jesus is not going to take
us out of the world. In fact, he prays
Mhm.
not that thou shouldest take them out of
the world, but keep them from the evil.
from the evil. We must seek first the
kingdom of God. That should be our
priority.
First. And God will take care of all the
other little minute things of our lives.
Seek first. That means the application
of your entire mind to the kingdom of
God through Christ.
Amen. Amen.
Nothing should don't Nothing Nothing
should dominate the mind like that. The
kingdom of God Really, the kingdom of
God is more than the place where you
live. It is first and foremost the rule
of Christ in your life.
Mhm. You see, the kingdom of God isn't
just a street of gold. It is the rule of
Christ in your life. So, Christ said,
"The kingdom of God is come unto you.
The kingdom of God is within you." So,
when we pray the Lord's prayer, "Thy
kingdom come. Thy will be done." His
will in our lives is his kingdom in our
life. The kingdom of God is first and
foremost the reign, the rule of Christ
in the person's life. That's where the
kingdom begins.
Mhm.
So, thy kingdom come. It isn't just the
second coming. Come into my life. Thy
will be done.
In earth as it is in heaven, yes. The
kingdom of God is the rule of God in the
life first.
The principle of his kingdom.
That's how I live. That's the kingdom of
God in me. And one day, if I'm faithful
to that, I'll actually live in a
physical kingdom that is pure, say
listen, streets of gold or whatever
else. One tree that bears 12 manner of
fruit.
Amen. Amen. Thank you so much, Aldis
Keith. That I'm going to
allow that to conclude our our official
questions. Mhm. Um and we have a couple
questions in the chat. Okay. I see that
Sovereign Hero has asked this question
here in Zoom.
Mhm.
It begins.
Lucifer reflected the Godhead so much so
that he was at times indistinguishable
from the Son.
In the new world, we will more perfectly
reflect the Godhead through Christ in
a way Lucifer never could, and we will
increase in him perpetually
Christ, and his light will be our light
in the sight of all the inhabitants of
the universe.
Mhm. In light of that
and given our role and design as a
special order of being that
intrinsically reflects the image of God
and the fact that Christ is now man
does that make us
mini gods? Absolutely not. No, no, no,
no. You can't make God. The verse said
Christ is now man, don't stop at Christ
is man. Christ is man and God. We We're
not mini gods. There's Father, Son, Holy
Ghost are the three divine beings, but
we are to be called like We are to be
godly. The character of God is to dwell
in us, but we're not of the substance of
God. You read Hebrews 1:3, speaking of
Jesus, who being the brightness of his
glory and the express image of his
person. Christ was the very substance of
God. We're not that. You see, Christ
said, "A spirit hath not flesh and bones
as you see me have." A spirit does not
have flesh and bones. God is a spirit.
The Holy Ghost is a spirit. Before
Christ came, he was a spirit. We're not
like that. But we're to be godly. The
character of God is to reside in us.
You have the Bible, human writers, but
you have inspiration in the Bible. You
have Jesus Christ, human and divine.
With us, we have We must have the
character of God. The very life of God
must be lived in us and through us.
We're dependent upon God.
If we're God, we're dependent on no one.
God is dependent upon no one, and only
God is like that. Father, Son, Holy
Ghost. We will be godly. In conflict and
courage page 21 paragraph five and the
white writes God created man for his
glory that after test and trial the
human family might become one with the
heavenly family. God's ultimate purpose
was to blend human and divine in a very
mysterious way. The product of that will
be astonishing.
But that will not make a human being God
nor will it make God less than he is.
There's a lot we just don't understand
but God cannot be made. God cannot be
created. He is creator. So no matter how
close we are to Christ, how much we
reflect him, we will still be created
beings.
Yes. You know, and Elder Ski, I also
want to say God will not allow sin to
rise up a second time. So
I know God will make that distinction
between who we are and who he is. Yes.
Now, I feel though that someone is
probably going to watch this and say,
"But what about Psalm 82 Mhm. verse six
where the Bible says, "And I I have
said, 'Ye are gods and all of you are
children of the most high.'" How do we
clarify this in the context that we are
not God?
Well, you'd have you'd have to look at
the Hebrew word for gods in that verse
to see what it really mean or whether it
has a capital G or little G. Because the
Bible says there's there's lords many
and gods many. You see? So does it have
a small G or big G and what is the
Hebrew word behind. But there's only
Father, Son, Holy Ghost. No one else is
divine. But the Bible says Sarah called
Abraham lord.
The Bible also calls God lord, you see?
But Sarah called the lord lord can refer
to God. It can also refer to someone in
charge, a ruler, a king can be called
lord. So Sarah called Abraham lord
recognizing his leadership role in the
family. Mhm.
Amen. Amen. Thank you, Elder Ski. Mhm.
Now, I did see a question here on
YouTube.
This is from S. Bra.
It is, "Isn't tiredness a result of
sin?" Is it what?
And Revelation
Isn't tiredness a result of sin? Mhm. In
Revelation 22:5, it states there will be
no night. More There will be no more
night. I assume that we wouldn't have to
sleep. Is that a true assumption?
Well, no, it's not a true assumption.
When you think of night, we cannot
believe or assume the night as we know
it now
is as dark as it was back then before
sin. A lot of things changed because of
sin.
The vast oceans we see now did not exist
when God created they're the result of
the flood. So we're not sure of what the
night looked like. We do know there was
a bright part of the day and a dark part
of the day. Whether the dark part was
absolute charcoal blackness, we don't
know. But in the new world, it will be a
reproduction at a greater level of
beauty of the old world, a restoration.
We won't be different beings. We will be
the same. The difference will be no sin.
So as in the days of Adam, the evening
and the morning were the first day, in
the new world, evening and morning first
day of well as well, second day, third
day. Or else how will we come to worship
him for one Sabbath to another, you see?
And so there will be evening and morning
but not necessarily the kind of charcoal
inky blackness that we have today.
Amen. Thank you, Elder Ski. And I see
someone else is asking, "Are we going to
sleep in the new world?" Well, yes, Adam
was supposed to sleep even before he
sinned. Yes, we'll sleep in the new
world. God doesn't sleep but humanity
sleeps.
Mhm.
Amen. Amen.
We even though we're redeemed,
we're not God.
And so a created being needs sustenance,
needs rest. A created being gets tired.
Now, in the new world we won't be as
tired as quickly as we are today. You
know, you climb two stairs and you're
out of breath. You know, you need EMT to
come take care of you. Not in the new
world. Are you following me? And so we
must not confuse the two. Being tired in
this world will be nothing like the new
world. It'll take a lot of exertion to
be tired in the new world. But we know
from Isaiah 40 God does not get tired.
He doesn't get weary. Why? Because he is
God.
But if you're not God, weariness will be
a part of your experience.
Mhm.
Not necessarily exhaustion, but
weariness. Yes, you're tired. You take a
break.
Mhm. Amen.
says that God rested and was refreshed.
That's what we read in there. I think
it's the Exodus 31:18 and he rested and
was refreshed. How does God get
refreshed? I'm not sure, but he was
refreshed. If God can be refreshed, we
need to be refreshed.
Mhm.
Amen. Amen.
So we probably have time for two more
questions.
All right. And okay, let me come here.
Believe Alana had a question.
As I
try to There's no one assisting you
today, Dr. Danisha. You're all by
yourself.
Um yes, yes.
Okay. Well, you're not alone. God is
with you. That's right. Alana has been
uh
putting the text in the chat, the Bible
text that you mentioned. Okay. Mhm. Uh
so she asked,
"Considering the new world, Mhm. how
would one know that they are shaken
out?" And she says like shaken out by
the last days. By the way, God being
refreshed, I think it's Exodus 31:17.
18 says he came down with the tables of
stone in his hand. Okay.
Okay.
They were written with the finger of
God. All right, what's that question?
How concerning the new world,
Mhm. how would one know that they are
shaken out? What do you mean shaken out?
I acci- She said like shaken out by the
last days.
So Alana, if you even want to add a
little bit more clarity, do you mean
like Okay.
You can feel free to add in the chat
more clarity so that we can under- Okay.
Is there another question?
Um okay, so Sovereign Hero is asking
that we finish this question. But before
we get there, Mhm. Jerry is asking, "Can
the desire to make it into the new world
be
selfish?"
If you pursue what God wants you to
pursue, that's not selfishness. God
wants you in the new world. That's his
desire for you.
If you cooperate with that desire,
that's not selfishness.
Mhm.
But I think I understand what he's
trying to say.
The Bible The Bible says
um he that findeth a wife findeth a good
thing. But you can make the pursuit of a
wife a little god in your life because
that's all that you think about or a
pursuit of a husband or a career or
money, whatever. I think that's
the direction which the person is coming
and I understand that perfectly. But
when we pursue what God wants us to
pursue, that's not selfishness.
Amen.
God wants us in his kingdom.
So he says, "Seek ye the kingdom first."
Amen. But heaven ultimately is the
presence of Jesus Christ.
So to seek the kingdom is to seek
Christ.
Amen. Amen. Thank you for highlighting
that. It's God's presence that makes the
difference. Mhm. Um
Yes, Brother Tulasi,
I'm giving you the opportunity to unmute
and ask your question relating to the
new world. So feel free to unmute and
ask your question.
Okay. Thank you very much.
Uh
so
first and foremost, I would like to say
thank you for the opportunity accorded
to me and I love you, Sister Danisha and
Pastor Andy Ski. Thank you. Thank you.
I like what you're doing.
Yes. Uh
I see your smile. My question is uh
is it possible for
sin to come again
in the new world? Is it possible for
what?
Sin to break out again in the new
Revelation 22:3.
Read that verse.
Revelation 22. Read from verse one of
Revelation 22, one to three.
Read out loud.
Okay.
So I'm there.
Okay, read for us.
And he showed me a pure river of water
of life, clear as crystal,
Yes, Revelation 22:1-3.
Mhm. And he showed me a pure river water
of life,
Mhm. clear as crystal proceeding from
the throne of God and the lamb of God.
Mhm. In the middle of it and on the
other side on and on either side of the
river was the tree of life which bore 12
fruits, each tree yielding each fruit
every month. The leaves of the tree were
for the healing of the nations. Verse
three.
pause for a minute. The first one tells
us there's a river of life. Verse two
tells us there's a tree of life. This is
a new heaven. In the first world, we had
a river of life, it flowed out of Eden.
We had a tree of life. So this is a
restoration. Now, here's what Read verse
three.
Verse three Verse three tells us,
"And there shall be no more curse." Ah,
okay. There shall be no more curse.
Mhm. That's God's guarantee. What is the
curse? It's death. What brings death?
Sin.
Where there's no curse because there's
no sin, there's no death. There will
no sin. That's why, my good brother,
thanks for asking the question, by the
way. And I've said this many times.
Those of you who watch YouTube, you may
have heard me. The first time God made
the
the world, he made the world first then
he made Adam and Eve. They did not ask
him if they wanted to be made. He just
made them. This time, before God makes
the new heaven and the new earth, he is
asking us, "Do you want to live in a
world without sin?"
Mhm. Accept Christ.
Those who enter the new world would have
made a choice. We do not want sin
anymore.
Mhm.
And God will seal that choice. So, those
that are holy, let them be holy still
forever.
So, there will be no more sin in the new
world, my good brother.
And we must live like that now. Get sin
out of our life. We must live that way
now.
I'm looking forward to meeting you in
heaven. Well, God bless you. God bless
you.
I'll be on the last bus entering. You'll
get there before me.
Uh amen. Amen. Amen.
Okay, so Joy Ram has asked, in the new
world, will will there be procreation?
Absolutely not. I hope no one starts to
cry. Absolutely not. There will be no
In Medical Ministry, page 99, paragraph
4, Ellen White said, "There are men who
expressed their belief that there will
be marriages and childbearing in the new
world. Those who accept such belief do
not know the sure word of prophecy. They
do not understand the scriptures."
Luke chapter 20: 34-36 make it very
clear there will be no marriages,
consequently no childbearing, because
the original purpose of marriage was to
produce children.
There will be no childbearing, no
marriage in the new world.
None.
Amen. Amen. Amen.
Okay, and Beauty House Capital is
asking, will I and my mother who has
passed and my daughter be able to live
in the same house that God has built? If
they choose to, of course.
We won't be robots. We have choices.
Yes.
Of course, you'll live in the same
house.
Now, you may have your own house
available to you, but you can live in
the same house, yes. When Jesus said, "I
go to in my Father's house are many
mansions." There's one for every
redeemed person.
There won't be a housing problem in the
new world. No, not at all.
And there won't be low-income housing,
either.
Amen to that, too.
All right. So, it is 3:00
and
Okay, I see someone
Did Alana clarify that question?
Uh Alana, she
Alana, sorry. Uh no, it's okay. Let me
come here.
Uh
All right.
She said she had to rethink it. Okay.
All right. Good thinking. Good thinking.
Um
Someone else. Mhm. A beautiful soldier
has asked, will babies that died grow up
in the new earth?
Will babies that died?
Yes.
Babies who are saved in the new world
will grow up.
God's will was that babies would grow
up.
Malachi 4:1-2.
For behold, the day cometh that shall
burn as an oven, and all the proud, yea,
all that do wickedly, shall be stubble.
And the day that cometh shall burn them
up, saith the Lord of hosts, that it
shall leave them neither root nor
branch. But unto you that fear my name
shall the Sun of righteousness arise
with healing in his wings, and ye shall
go forth and grow up as calves of the
stall. All babies will grow up. Those of
us who are the size of midgets right
now, we will grow up. Yes.
Ultimately, there will only be adults in
heaven.
Ultimately, all children will grow up.
Amen. Amen. Amen.
Okay, Elder Skeete. Um I'll make this
the last question. All right.
From Sovereign Hero, what is the
significance of palm trees, I'm guessing
in heaven, and what will be its
significance in the Well, what is the
true significance of the palm, and what
will it what will be its significance in
the new world? Well, when Jesus entered
Jerusalem, they were waving palm trees
to celebrate uh
which is what you did for kings. And so,
his disciples and the crowd were waving
palm palm leaves.
Uh
so, the palm may be a symbol of a kingly
procession.
Many years ago, I went to a northern
Uganda to visit the church that had been
set up as a result of a crusade.
And um a lot of the church members all
came out. They were waiting. We were
hours late.
And when they identified the car I was
in, about four cars traveling, they were
waving branches and and uh what the word
is, they were making some noises. I
forgot the word. They were waving these
palm branches. Here comes the preacher.
And so, when Christ entered Jerusalem,
they were waving palm branches and
scattering them before him. So, they're
a symbol of the the the procession of a
king.
That's the best I can tell you.
Amen. Amen. And indeed, we'll be living
with the King of kings and the Lord of
lords in the new
and the new earth. Astonishing.
Indeed. Indeed. I want to thank all of
you that have joined. Sister Virtuous
Woman in Christ, thank you for being
here on the live on YouTube. Those of
you that have joined from on Zoom,
YouTube, and Facebook, we are grateful
for your presence. And of course, Elder
Randy Skeete, thank you for giving
freely of your time. You could have been
a million places today, literally, but
you took the time to join us today in
discussing
the new world. So, may the Lord bless
you richly, and pray that he will grant
you the desires of your heart. And
indeed, in the new heaven and the new
earth, we want to be all all of us. We
want to be together. And who knows,
maybe we'll have a house next to each
other.
Okay.
Yes.
That sounds fine by me. Yes, may the
Lord bless you and Sister Skeete. And if
we don't meet again face to face on this
earth, I pray that we will meet in the
new one. And that goes for all those who
are listening. Mhm.
Yes.
Yes, indeed.
Yes. Let me make an appeal. Let me make
an appeal. Yes.
I know we're busy with work,
with studies,
with relationships, with whatever.
But in all this busyness, if there's
such a word, do not forget
Christ is coming back.
He's coming back for those who are
ready.
He is not coming back to get you ready.
He is coming back for those who are
ready.
That should be occupying your time now,
getting ready for the return of Jesus
Christ. And the highest form of
readiness is to have him enthroned in
your heart, directing, guiding every
facet of your life. This is total
surrender. Do not allow the very
legitimate cares of this life to cause
you to live to lose heaven. Let me say
it again. Notice I said legitimate cares
of this life. Do not allow them to cause
you to lose a place in God's kingdom.
Losing a place in God's kingdom is no
different from losing intimate
face-to-face fellowship with Jesus
Christ. Do not allow the cares of this
life to cause you to lose that. Be
prepared day by day
to meet your savior. God bless you. Put
a double blessing on your children.
Amen. And amen. Thank you so much, Elder
Skeete, for that appeal.
Very needed.
All right, friends. So, in light of that
theme, I'm going to sing a song, I have
fixed my mind on another time.
I have fixed my mind
on another time.
On another
time.
And here I mean
to stand until
God gives me more light.
And that is today.
Today.
Today until
he comes.
I have fixed my mind
on another time.
On another
time.
I have set my course on the narrow way.
On the narrow
way.
For I know the time is close at hand for
which I watch and
pray.
And that is today.
Today.
Today until he comes.
I have set my course on the narrow way.
On the narrow
way.
Mhm.
so, Lord, come quickly.
This is my fervent
prayer,
for
I've caught a glimpse of glory,
and I'm longing to be there.
And Christ is the
and in glorious fire, with all the
saints
amassed,
and we'll rise with those who sleep no
more to meet him in
the air.
When shall the Son
of man appear?
appear?
The Son of man
appear.
Even so,
Lord, come quickly.
This is my fervent
prayer,
for I've caught a glimpse of glory,
and I'm longing to be there,
and I'm longing
to
be there.
I have fixed my mind
on another
time.
On another
Amen and amen. We will now have our
closing prayer by Sister Wasan Palmer.
Let me
allow you to unmute.
Thank you. Let us pray.
Heavenly Father, thank you for this
wonderful study,
beautiful music from our dear sister
Nisha. Lord, I pray that you may
continue to anoint her, continue to
anoint um Pastor Randy Skeete, Lord,
that he may continue to excel into
uh be used by you to guide us, used by
you to inspire us
to study your word and to set our hearts
on heaven and heaven alone. Pray that as
we leave this study, you would inspire
us and help us to carry these lessons
with us into our lives, and to more than
carry them and more than apply them, to
also share them, because that's what you
have us to do.
Save us from selfishness and sin, give
us the ultimate victory. We give you
thanks in Jesus' name. Amen.
Amen. And before you before you go,
because my computer is being very slow.
Okay. We are
Even though I'm clicking replace
spotlight, it's not replacing you, so
I do want you to be seen.
There we go.
Thank you for joining us. Are you at
Christian Fellowship right now?
Sorry. I'm at New Rochelle right now,
SDA.
Yeah.
Well, thank you. Thank you so much for
giving of your time and joining all the
way from New Rochelle
to do this prayer.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
And to those of you that were on the
Zoom and are on right now, those of you
that joined on YouTube, thank you so
much for your presence. Thank you for
your time. Virtuous Women in Christ,
Emmanuel Yeboah, Bob Obogo, Angel
Brown, Jerry, Beautiful Soldier, Bird of
Paradise, Joy Ram, Joyce M. McGill,
Carla Dennis, Amanda Wallace, thank you
for joining all the way from England.
God bless you.
Uh Beauty House Capital, and have I
gotten Charles Mayoro?
Uh Jeronimo
Jeronimo Aponte, Matthew McDonald,
Tulissi, you were on the Zoom as well.
Tech Cast Katie, Sister Desiree Wilson,
Sister Cleo, my mother, all of you.
Thank you so much for your presence.
May the Lord bless you abundantly.
And truly, let us fix our minds on
another time. God has something better
for us. Mainza, Chiobeka, Sovereign
Hero, and 598159,
along with Alana Kwashi, thank you for
being here on the Zoom. God bless you
all, and until next time, let's remain
faithful. Take care and God bless.